hi there i'm marine wilson and i'm reza
aslan and i am stimulating my god spot
right now okay i'm feeling really
uncomfortable and i'm about to sue you
no dude my brain man i'm stimulating my
brain my brain okay well i can get into
that
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so rain tell me about a
transcendent experience that you've had
recently
um
i've had a couple of truly transcendent
experiences in my life i would say that
first and foremost i've seen radiohead
live
i think five times i'd say five to me
and um
there was one time i think it was the
second time i saw them at the hollywood
bowl it really was the closest thing to
a religious experience that i've ever
had now i'm a religious person i am a
card-carrying member of a religion and
yet oddly enough my most religious
experience my most most spiritual
transcendent experience was at this
radiohead concert i mean i knew the
songs so well the light show was amazing
the sound was incredible i was there
with some friends we all loved radiohead
equally and there's something about
their music that is it's trance inducing
yeah and it's also like there is such a
yearning
uh in their lyrics and in their music
that it um
it really tugs at my heart and like
just something like you know a thousand
two thousand people singing along with
the lyrics and i really just felt for a
super long period of time completely out
of my body i didn't have any concerns
and anxieties cares i didn't feel like
rain wilson i just felt like i was in
some kind of ocean of bliss yeah dude
i've had a similar experience at
radiohead concerts i think probably
if i were to talk about my
clearest transcendent experience
uh it was i guess i had just graduated
from undergrad i think and i was just
you know i was kind of in a depressed
place and i was driving around the
country i literally just packed up a car
with a guitar
and uh a sleeping bag and a channel look
at you yeah and just drove around i made
it all the way to canada and this was
this actually happened uh in your neck
of the woods and rainier okay it was in
rainier i remember i was hiking along
and i was there's like there was this
little river and i just decided you know
i'm it's not like i've got anyone
waiting back at the campsite for me or
something i'm just gonna follow this
river until i find its source
so i was following it and you know it
became uh thinner and then it became
like a trickle and it just kept getting
higher and higher and higher and then i
saw the source and it was this
uh glacier this gigantic glacier that
had um kind of like broken in the middle
so it formed a v
basically and it was
melting
you know little drops at a time
but this this this thing
was this mighty river
down where i was
camped yeah and i just kind of sat there
for a little bit and and meditated and
just you know started ugly crying for no
reason
um and it was a deeply transcendent
experience
it makes me think you know
you've had transcendent experiences i've
had transcendent experiences everyone
has sure
experience of nature the experience of
music
love
watching your a child be born yeah you
know all of those children
steps for instance
and
is is the thing that's happening
is it
something that's out there
that i'm tapping into right some field
yeah some energy some
right or
is it in here to put it in its
uh you know most basic and and perhaps
an elegant way
does god exist in my brain
maybe he's inside all of us but not in
any kind of metaphorical sense but
literally literally yeah yeah in our
neuro
chemistry and uh our nerves so we we
touched a little bit uh on this same
thing in our episode on memory
um god transcendence connected to our
brains what happens in our brains
fortunately we have an amazing guest
today that might be able to help shed
some light on
this
very same topic dr andrew newberg is an
expert in neurotheology which i've never
heard of before until this moment no
that i think he just made that up
neurotheology that's [ __ ] the study
of the brain and religion he's director
of research the marcus institute of
integrative health and a professor at
thomas jefferson university he does he
teaches religious studies and
uh is a neuroscientist and researcher an
author of ten books including one of my
favorites and it's one of the first
books we discussed when we started
talking about doing this podcast and i
really enjoyed it it's called why god
won't go away and it's the link between
god and the brain um you know it's it's
scientific don't worry it's not like um
what the bleep do we know or the secret
it's not something like
like hippy dippy claptrap uh it's it's
for real so we've got a
legit scientist a legit scientist here
with us
so i'm dr andrew newberg i'm the
research director at the marcus
institute of integrative health at
thomas jefferson university in
philadelphia
over the past 25 to 30 years i have
actually been doing a lot of research
looking at how the brain works in a
variety of different neurological and
psychological problems
but my real focus over the last 25 years
has been the study of various religious
and spiritual experiences and practices
practices like meditation and prayer
mystical experiences and how that all is
connected with the human brain okay so
this is like the kind of stuff that
religious nerds like rain and me
we go crazy for right i mean it like
gives us tingles
like the equivalent of like the new star
wars coming out like let's talk religion
in the brain right this is the new
avenger movie for us but this is oh yeah
where does a mystical experience live
neurologically so let's talk about this
yeah uh absolutely i think i think
at this point it's
pretty much accepted right i don't know
if there's any any more questions about
the fact that the religious experience
is a neurological phenomenon that's kind
of a fact now right
well certainly when you think about
religious experiences there is something
going on in the brain now i i tend to
take a bit of a neutral stance into
exactly what is going on or how it's
happening
you know our brain reacts to the world
around us as well as kind of generates
our own sense of reality so when
somebody is praying and they experience
god's presence in their in their world
um certainly there's something going on
in the brain whether god is there doing
that to their brain or whether it is
something that is purely a manifestation
of the brain
is a very fascinating uh and problematic
philosophical and theological question
but we can certainly talk about what's
going on in the brain when people have
these experiences yeah yeah we're just
talking about the how right now yeah
we'll get to the why later yeah okay i
don't sound god's fingers at work in the
brain you know making things pulse or
something like that but it is good to
know that there are certain areas of the
brain that light up when you're having a
mystical or transcendent experience yes
but of course the thing exactly rain and
i always talk about is why is this
controversial where else would the
religious experience
exist except in the brain i mean every
every experience you have ever had in
your life without exception
exists in the brain so why wouldn't the
spiritual one also be in the brain
i guess for some people
like the richard dawkins of the world
uh the fact that it is it is an
experience located in the brain somehow
delegitimizes
the experience and so i think for some
religious people
they're they're less prone to accept
the sort of biological circumstances of
their religious experience because they
think doing so would just give
ammunition to people to just simply
delegitimize the experience what do you
what do you say to that well yeah
absolutely i mean maybe another
example would be you know feeling love
for your spouse or your child i mean
obviously again
that is experienced in your brain it
doesn't mean that your child doesn't
exist it doesn't mean that you don't
have the love you do feel all those
things and those feelings are
extraordinarily important in a person's
life so i i agree i mean i think it's
it's valuable to be able to see what's
going on in the brain to help us
understand that but it does not uh
inherently delegitimize it um but it
does it's a piece of information that is
part of this larger question about the
reality of these experiences and what
they may mean for people
folks is the piece of plastic in your
wallet doing enough for you because with
the secured chime credit builder visa
credit card you can start building
credit with everyday purchases and
on-time payments
you see with credit builder members can
increase their credit history with no
annual fees or interest and having a
good credit score can mean getting
better car loan rates or renting
apartments easier or just bragging
rights around the dinner table so
continue your credit journey with chime
sign up takes only two minutes and
doesn't affect your credit score get
started at chime dot com slash milkshake
that's chime dot com slash milkshake
the chime credit builder visa credit
card is issued by stride bank n a
pursuant to a license from visa usa
chime checking account and 200
qualifying direct deposit required to
apply for the secured chime credit
builder visa credit card regular on-time
payment history can have a positive
impact on your credit score impact to
score may vary and some user scores may
not improve
hey rayne what do you think of my shirt
uh nice shirt reza what do you think of
my shirt that's a really nice shirt yep
we got some nice shirts on why is that
do you think because we got it from buck
mason
folks we all have our favorite go-to's
right shirts sweaters jeans the stuff
you wear all the time and then most of
the stuff just sits in your closet well
i was getting dressed this morning and
realized my go-to's are from buck mason
so did reza buck mason's clothes are
second to none they're timeless and
never go out of style everything i own
fits great right out of the box becomes
my new favorite already look at this
it's so soft it's really soft i love
this i mean this feels it's it looks
like a t-shirt from the outside but it
feels like a hug
they make all the essentials and i
basically have one of everything they
make jeans i've got jeans they make
shirts i got like three of those buck
mason shirts they got a jacket i wore
this like cool black wool jacket the
other day like yeah i looked good so
once you try buck mason they'll become
your go-to's as well head over to
buckmason.com milkshake and get a free
t-shirt guys a free t-shirt with your
first order that's
b-u-c-k-m-a-s-o-n dot com slash
milkshake to get a free t-shirt with
your first order
buckmason
buckmason.com
milkshake
you make one other point which i thought
was really fascinating which is that
this kind of uh let's just say religious
belief or religious experience spiritual
experience whatever
that
it is a functioning of the brain
but
it it also in some way
either assists in sort of other
cognitive processes or
like it's good for the brain i mean we
all know that it's universal and in the
brain why we'll get to that we have no
idea but but uh but you're saying that
it actually
uh assists the brain in some way
uh and it's sort of normal quote-unquote
non-spiritual functioning what do you
mean by that right well whenever you're
doing a practice like meditation for
example there's a lot of you you're you
know as you were saying a lot of this is
in the brain so where in the brain well
there's a lot of different elements to
these experiences in these practices
there's cognitive elements so that
includes concentrating maybe you're
concentrating on a prayer maybe you're
concentrating on an uh an image that you
create in your mind maybe you're
concentrating on a candle but
concentration is an important process so
if you're if you've gotten very good at
concentrating during meditation what the
research also shows is that you're
probably going to be pretty good at
concentrating on other things
concentrating on solving a problem at
work uh taking a test if you're a
student at school so there that's where
the advantages can come in in terms of
cognitive abilities uh now when it comes
to the emotional aspect that's another
piece of this uh when people meditate
and pray
that tends to be associated with
reductions in anxiety stress uh
depression and so when people are
battling those kinds of issues in their
lives even if it's just normal anxiety
or or normal depression that you might
have is you know because things haven't
been going well for you or you're
worried about you know getting fired at
work or whatever then engaging in these
practices can have a benefit from that
kind of a perspective as well in fact
there's evidence to show that these
practices help people to regulate their
emotional responses more effectively so
there's a lot of different ways in which
religious and spiritual practices can
ultimately be beneficial for people and
of course if you you know start to get
into the kind of the larger global uh
aspect of it you know if you're
connected to a community of individuals
then you have the social interaction the
social support and all of that has a
benefit for our brain as well as our
bodies so so there's a lot of different
ways in which these these practices can
have a beneficial impact for for people
yeah this is the kind of [ __ ] that brain
says all the time
do i yeah you say this all you were
constantly going on about how like
religion is actually good for you it
makes you feel better it makes you
healthier it makes you like you know the
amount of studies that have been done
around the beneficial effects of
meditation are you know innumerable
um prayer as well but then also
compassion and connection in community
uh which religion also gives you and i
imagine but here's where here's so tell
us what you've learned about what
happens in the brain
through these various
spiritual experiences and i like the way
that you haven't lumped all spiritual
experiences into one experience there's
like you said there's
concentration is one there's emotions is
another one i imagine like feeling
connected is maybe another there might
be lots of different ways it might evoke
memories there's lots of different ways
that this
the this experience might you know light
up your brain like a like a pinball
machine but what have you specifically
learned about how this stuff works in
the gray matter itself
sure well so you first of all you're
absolutely right i mean a lot of the
research that we have also done that's
kind of led up to the imaging studies of
the brain um asks people to describe
these experiences and and there is such
tremendous diversity and multiplicity of
these experiences so there really is not
just one way in which people have these
experiences and there are many different
cognitive emotional experiential
elements that become part of that now
when you extrapolate that to what's
going on in the brain we can start to
look at which elements link up with
different functions of the brain so for
example we've already talked about
concentration
so if you begin to
concentrate on a particular prayer or
meditative practice then what we see on
the brain scans is that the concentrate
of areas of the brain the frontal lobes
turn on and so the frontal lobes become
more active and that helps the person to
concentrate more and more on the object
of their practice
interestingly it also helps to screen
out other information so and that's also
an important part of how our brain helps
to concentrate it's not just focusing on
something but screening out other things
in fact that's why meditation may be
good for people with like adhd because
it helps you to concentrate but it also
helps you to screen out now we've talked
about the emotional processes so when
somebody has a very powerful emotional
experience they feel intense compassion
love joy awe
then we expect to see changes in the
emotional centers of the brain the
limbic system uh such as the uh the
amygdala which a lot of people have
heard of and that that turns on when
something of very powerful emotions
affects us could be good could be bad um
but certainly if something of great
motivational importance appears before
us or we think about you know the
meaning of god in our lives or something
like that then that turns on these
emotional centers and that's part of why
the person feels very intensely
emotional about them and then you also
mentioned connectedness and this is
another area that we've been
particularly fascinated by
that's a very common theme in a lot of
these descriptions of these experiences
the sense of oneness the loss of the
sense of self the feeling of
connectedness with other people with god
the universe whatever it is um and
there's an area of our brain the
parietal lobe which is located in the
back of our brain that usually takes our
sensory information and helps us to
create our sense of self and what we
have observed on brain scan studies is
that this area during these experiences
actually starts to quiet down and that
makes sense because yeah that makes a
lot of sense though because if it
normally turns on to give us our sense
of self then when the person loses their
sense of self the area should go the
other way it starts to quiet down and we
lose that sense of self we lose the the
boundary between our self and the rest
of the world or other people or god or
the universe whatever the person's
experiences
and this is again a very common thing
that we tend to see in these kinds of
experiences and you know part of what
i've learned from all of this is that
there isn't just one part of the brain
there isn't one little area of the brain
that turns on when you know you walk
into church or whatever
it's all these different parts that are
form a kind of network and how you
utilize them how you access them really
depends on what you're doing and what
you're experiencing so if you don't have
much of an emotional reaction well
you're not going to use your emotional
centers very much whereas if you do have
a powerful emotional reaction then we
would expect to see that
this is fascinating the loss of self
thing
for thousands of years the goal of
mystics has been precisely to lose this
to lose the self i see that you did this
study with the buddhist michael bame is
that how you say his name yes uh
and another aspect of reducing the
parietal lobes is also losing your sense
of time and place
so there's a a timelessness and a
honestness and selflessness
in just reducing the activity in this
one area of the brain so is there are
there exercises where we can all kind of
like reduce the the functioning of the
parietal lobes and and get a little
closer to nirvana and does drugs help
well that's a that's a whole other
discussion to have um and and the answer
is very probably yes um but um
you know obviously practices like
meditation can do that but but people
can find these kinds of processes
through uh a lot of different kinds of
things a lot of people come up to me and
say my spirituality is creativity is is
music is art and certainly you know a
great musician can lose themselves as
they get into the piece of music a great
artist can lose themselves you know to
become one with the sculpture one with
the painting for example my spirituality
is in podcasting when i'm positive
right
i'm like surfing in the divine light
baby yeah yeah well and and you
mentioned surfing i i've talked to
people about you know the experience
that people have surfing uh athletes in
the zone um you know so there there are
many examples where people kind of lose
that sense of self and that seems to be
a very powerful experience a very
positive experience for people because
you feel more connected to something
that is greater than the self
[Music]
so i'm going to go off topic a little
bit here
and you know as i'm listening to you and
as we're having this incredible
discussion i'm i'm kind of getting
pissed off oh
and yeah you don't want to make rain
angry you won't like rain i wasn't
trying as angry
i'm worried i'm not gonna bring up trump
this
this but this is about our society so
um when you know when you raise kids you
start to see the world in a different
way because you see that all the
different ways that the world wants to
attack our kids and get in their brains
and in their consciousness and in their
eyeballs and everything on television in
the media on social media and
advertising and marketing and in
capitalist kind of merchandising is to
to say this one thing like if you can
satisfy yourself more you will be
happier if you can get more stuff if
people can look at you for the stuff
that you have if they will like you for
the stuff that you have if you can do
more to you know this whole thing right
now about self-care like yes i get it we
should do some self-care we shouldn't
just treat ourselves like [ __ ] we should
get some sleep and get an occasional
massage whatever but this whole thing
like self-care self-care self-care goop
you know all this stuff like what
lotions do we put on our anus in the
morning everything we're getting
inundated with is take care of the self
promote the self uplift the self get
more stuff for the self this will make
you happier and it is exactly the
opposite opposite and it is exactly like
180 degrees scientifically proven to
absolutely be wrong
now
of course some people are poor and
they're hungry and they don't have a
shirt and they want a shirt and that's
not what i'm talking about i'm talking
about i get it you okay you get what i'm
talking about so oh yeah i don't know
what this has to do with the brain but
it's interesting this kind of whole bill
of goods that people are being fed
especially young people and oftentimes
buy into like oh the more likes i get on
instagram the more popular i'll be the
more status i'll have and then i'll be
more liked and then i'll be more happy
and we're getting unhappier and
unhappier all the time right well you
know i i think as with everything in the
world um including the brain there's
always sort of the plus side and the
minus side and there's the good and the
bad that comes with these things and so
as you said i mean
obviously our brains are designed to
protect the self i mean we have to eat
we have to you know we have to
survive i mean that's one of the main
functions that the brain has for us is
is self-maintenance it helps to take
care of ourselves it helps us to eat
survive communicate with others and that
is a fundamental importance to the brain
but on the other hand uh our brain also
has the ability to connect with the
world and to transcend it uh transcend
itself in many ways and so
that it you know that is this sort of uh
conundrum paradox if you will where
we're kind of you know we want to feel
it connected to the world but we want to
protect the self and
it's it's a challenge for the brain i
mean it's like it's like being angry and
happy i mean sometimes you have to be
angry at people but ideally you know to
sometimes you have to be angry at your
child because they did something wrong
and you need to correct that uh on the
other hand you know you have to show
them love and so there's there's always
a balance if you do it one way you know
too much one way or the other uh it
winds up being a problem and you know
even going back to our discussion about
these spiritual experiences and that
feeling of connectedness well you know
part we one of the statements that my
colleagues and i used to talk about was
that that the practices are kind of
these morally neutral technologies and
so if you use this kind of ritualistic
meditative practice for
bad things
well it's very good at helping people to
see the world in a very negative way i
mean cults uh terrorism and things like
that there's no secret i think that's
what this is secret you know what i'm
talking about
yeah let's see i remember the secret i
never i never read that
i don't know there is the downside of it
and and so you know it's not just
feeling connected but it's what you feel
connected to and if you just feel
connected to a group
that is very exclusive then you're going
to be angry and hateful and vengeful to
people who are outside of that group
whereas if your group is all of humanity
then you do feel compassion and love and
warmth forever and inclusiveness for
everyone so that's well said so yeah so
yeah it's not just doing these things
but it's how one does these things
so rain lately i've been getting all
these emails from uh my mother-in-law
uh-oh i know it's it's how it's worrying
like you're immediately like why would
you be getting regular emails from your
mother-in-law but i'll tell you why it's
because i signed her up for story worth
i mean every time she answers one of
these story worth questions
it's like i feel closer to her i feel
i feel like a a good son-in-law story
worth folks it's an online service that
helps you and your loved ones connect
through sharing stories and memories and
preserves them for years to come
every week story worth emails your mom a
thought-provoking question of your
choice from a vast pool of possible
options they have lots of unique prompts
like what's some of the best advice your
mother ever gave you or if you were to
do it all over again what would you do
differently and why did you let your
daughter marry reza etc
i'm sure you had a lot of interesting
questions that were posed to your
mother-in-law and listen mother's day
people it's right around the corner it's
right around the corner this is a great
mother's day gift this is what happens
after a year of sending all these
questions and accumulating the answers
story worth then compiles it all
into
uh like this beautiful keepsake book and
then you can add photos to it and then
the whole family can share it
for generations so
you know story worth
it's not often that i get to say this
sentence but uh thanks for making me a
better husband so give all the moms in
your life a meaningful gift you'll both
cherish for years story worth right now
for a limited time you'll save ten
dollars on your first purchase when you
go to story worth dot com slash
milkshake that's s t o r y w o r t h dot
com slash milkshake to save ten dollars
on your first purchase
storyworth.com
milkshake
hey if you've ever recently bought
anything you've probably noticed that
prices have gone up on everything i mean
everything it's crazy i bought some
crackers the other day they were like
six dollars seven dollars
and also on essentials like gas
groceries utilities that's why it's
great to use good rx
good rx is free and easy to use and
works whether you do or do not have
insurance and even if you have insurance
good rx may actually beat your copay
price you can check goodrx online or
their app which just happens to be one
of the most downloaded medical apps ever
from there you can find prescription
savings at over 70 000 reza 70 000
pharmacies nationwide like cvs kroger
walgreens rite aids bonds walmart many
many many many more you know i i've said
this before i have excellent insurance i
am a an an employee of the university of
california i got that like i got that
like pension i got like the the kind of
insurance that chrysler workers in the
50s had like that's the kind of
insurance that i have impressive and
even then
goodrx beat
the price of one of my prescriptions
even then
for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions check goodrx go to good r
x dot com slash milkshake that's good rx
the two letters dot com slash milkshake
good rx.com milkshake good rx is not
insurance but can be used in place of
insurance medicare and medicaid in 2021
in fact goodrx users saved 81 percent on
retail prescription prices
so so you can develop these kind of more
advanced or quote unquote higher
uh
aspects of the brain they can be
exercised like going to the gym kind of
maybe well absolutely and so you know
some of the work that my myself and my
colleagues have done as well as a few
others have actually documented the
changes that occur in the brain as a
result of doing these practices so for
example we studied people initially and
then we sent them through a meditation a
very simple meditation program it was
called kirtan kriya and you just have to
repeat certain phrases it's very
concentrative and they did it for 12
minutes a day for eight weeks and when
they came back their frontal lobes were
more active just at baseline not while
they were doing the practice but just at
rest their frontal lobes were more
active and it was consistent with
improvements in their concentrated
abilities
other people have found some studies
which are really interesting as well
that have shown that those people who
are long-term meditators literally have
thicker frontal lobes than those people
who don't and so as you know to take
your analogy very literally yeah
yeah
well but you know just like a muscle um
the you know the more you use it the
more active it becomes and actually the
bigger it becomes the neurons and and
the brain itself becomes bigger and
appears to be associated with improved
concentration improve function so so
absolutely you know you can train your
brain we've seen other studies that show
evidence of this training effect um that
the more you do it uh the more it has an
impact on the way your brain functions
and one last thing to say about that
particular thing is that you know if you
want to get really good at
playing the violin well you're gonna you
have to practice the violin you don't
practice the flute you've got to
practice the violin so there are
specific ways of training the brain on
the other hand there are other ways of
developing general functions so for
example uh you know maybe
exercising is something that is good no
matter what you want to do you know
whether you want to become a good
athlete or a good musician you know you
got to be in good shape so
you know learning to develop your
muscles learning to become more aerobic
you know by taking walks or jogging you
know those are general things that can
be good for us no matter what we're
trying to focus on and to some degree
spiritual practices seem to be of that
ilk you know that that they kind of
generally help the brain even though
they don't necessarily make us better at
doing crossword puzzles per se
but if you learn how to do crossword
puzzles and on top of that you're you're
doing meditation you're probably going
to you know that's going to augment the
way in which your your brain is
functioning uh can we bring it back to
drugs for a moment absolutely let's talk
about drugs from it i mean let's do all
joking aside i mean our most ancient
religious texts mention the use of
mind-altering substances uh in in the
vedas it's called soma and the avesta
it's called homa
we've gone into
caves that are 40 50 000 years old and
have seen
uh fairly clear evidence um
of yeah well of altered states you know
how those alter we we're not exactly
sure how they achieved those altered
states but very clear that altered
states was part of whatever was going on
but i guess my question to you is
how much of the sort of unlocking of
this potential that exists within the
brains
can legitimately involved the use of
drugs i'm asking for a friend
[Laughter]
when you talk about psychedelic
experiences this is a very important
part of neurotheology research and
scholarship for several reasons
one is that we know where these drugs go
so for example we know that psilocybin
and a lot of the psychedelic drugs
actually affect the serotonin system in
the brain the the chemical the
neurotransmitter serotonin and so you
know it's not just enough to say that
the frontal lobes turn on or the
parietal lobes turn off but some of the
work that we've been doing has been
leading more and more to understanding
not only what areas of the brain are
involved but how they get involved and
so these neurotransmitter studies and
psychedelics really help us to
understand that now you know that being
said we also want to look at what the
experiences are like and actually in a
survey that we have run uh over the last
10 years where we've asked people about
their most intense spiritual experiences
and we've gotten a couple thousand
responses to that we looked at those
experiences that were had under the
influence of a psychedelic versus those
that were more you know
non-pharmacological or more natural so
if you want to use that term and there
is a great deal of equivalency in terms
of the intensity in terms of the power
in terms of the meaning and even in
terms of the spirituality and other
investigators have seen the same kind of
thing so so i think uh you know again
there's always kind of a good and a bad
but but for the you know under the right
circumstances for the right kind of
person the ability to utilize these
kinds of substances as a way of getting
the brain to experience something very
powerful very important very meaningful
there's a lot of evidence to support
that and it helps us to understand the
physiological basis of that so that we
can
you know use this kind of
neurotheological research to understand
even more
how our brain becomes religious and
spiritual but speaking as someone who's
had some addiction issues in my past i
want to also bring up
uh and this may be obvious you can't get
addicted to meditation i guess maybe you
can but i have a cousin who was
microdosing
acid for several years and it started as
like religious experimentation and
meanwhile he's he's fried and he's
living in a motel room in yakima so it's
uh it didn't work out so well for him
right that path and it's something to be
cautious about absolutely you know
nothing is perfect and everything has
potential problems for different kinds
of people and that's why we have to be
very cautious about saying oh yeah
everybody should take you know
psilocybin or something
because there are times where it can go
bad it can be problematic it can lead to
addictions so again you know that to me
that from a neurotheological perspective
one of the real exciting parts of this
research going forward is to look at the
good and the bad so you know while we
can talk about how religion and
spirituality are generally good for
people which i think as you mentioned
you know there's a lot of research to
support that's the case
but there are times where it goes wrong
and goes bad and and we need to learn
about that too
[Music]
okay so let's say i'm walking down the
street i'm having this profound
religious experience
um and i'm seeing colors and
experiencing like oneness with with all
things but then it turns out i just have
like a brain tumor i'm pretty sure this
is a stroke you just described a stroke
no that's what i'm saying like so it's
possible to go the other way too right
like to have things affect your brain
that just
fool you into thinking you're having
some kind of religious experience so
well absolutely that you know this is
another part of neuro theology research
which is you know we talked about drugs
we talked about practices like
meditation now there's the whole sort of
neurological psychiatric
scenario of things i mean uh there are
interesting studies that have looked at
people who have
various
injuries to the brain tumors and so
forth and they have found for example
that those people who have some kind of
abnormality in the parietal lobe are
actually more likely to express feelings
of self-transcendence than those people
who have
abnormalities tumors in the frontal lobe
so you know if we talk about the
parietal lobes being involved in that
spatial representation of the self and
that sense of self it makes a lot of
sense that if that area is disrupted
that you are more likely to have an
experience of the loss of self and and
that kind of spatial
experience there was a a woman named
jill bolti taylor who wrote a book
called my stroke of insight who had a
stroke in the left hemisphere of her
brain and developed a mystical
experience and so you know that those
are there's a whole other piece of
knowledge and information that we have
to understand the relationship between
the brain and these experiences and so
it gives us something to look at
something to learn about now you know
again
you know i'll get metaphysical on you
guys for a second um what does this mean
you know is it possible
that through drugs or through you know
the effect of a tumor that our brain
winds up operating on a level that we
are able to perceive the world in ways
that are different
than what we do in our normal everyday
life i mean in our everyday life i can't
see the ultraviolet or i can't you know
i can't see radio waves unless i got a
radio um but what would happen if you're
but they exist and what would happen if
my brain changed in such a way that
suddenly i can see things that i
wouldn't be able to see before or hear
things that i wouldn't be able to see
before um now again i mean i'm not
saying that that that that that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that that that that that that is driving
a science fiction film that i would go
see on the opening weekend sounds good
but yeah you know those are the kinds of
things that we have to be careful about
exactly what we conclude just simply
because somebody who's got a brain tumor
sees the world differently we don't know
exactly what that means in terms of the
actual nature of reality and that
question about where the real reality is
that to me
is the fundamental question that has
driven all of my interest in this field
and what drives the field of
neurotheology
so in other words it's not exactly it it
would be incorrect to call it a
malfunction necessarily right exactly it
could just be
a sort of a jump start you know of how
the the brain
um
of what the brain can be capable of in
other words exactly
[Music]
all right let's get deep shall we let's
let's move from the physical to the
metaphysical okay we are now at a place
where we can say
with a
fair measure of confidence
that whatever the spiritual experience
is it's a neurological phenomenon it
exists in our brains it's part of our
normal cognitive processes that means it
exists in everybody's brain
it must have evolved alongside of us we
don't know exactly why there are a lot
of ideas i know you have ideas why maybe
it's because of our pattern recognition
maybe it's because of our propensity to
find agency you know in natural
phenomena maybe it has to do with theory
of mind whatever but the why forget
about that let's just move that aside
for a minute but what is a fact
is that
this is an ability
that exists in every human being
from you know the earliest stages of our
evolution that very likely actually
there's an enormous amount of
archaeological
uh evidence to indicate that this is an
ability that existed
in previous human uh species not just in
hormones neanderthals right yeah exactly
okay all right doesn't that mean that
we're meant
to
be spiritual beings i mean doesn't that
mean
that this is how we are supposed to be
if we're wired that way i mean we are
literally wired this way we've always
been wired this way not just our species
but previous species of of humans
this is an elemental part
of the human condition
yes
right i mean that you know uh that's why
i wrote the book why god won't go away
you know that that it's something we are
spiritual beings we are just spiritual
beings it's something that's a part of
us yes exactly now you know again you
can get into the why and obviously if
you're religious you'd say well of
course we're like that because there's
god and that's why you know it makes
sense that we would be built that way um
you know and as you said even if you're
an evolutionary biologist uh there's
something about being spiritual about
being religious about having these
making these kinds of connections having
these kinds of feelings that does seem
to match up very well with what our
brain is designed to do to help us and
and how we work as human beings so i
would agree that it is a fundamental
piece of who we are and as you said the
the archaeological and anthropological
evidence points to that as well okay so
then i guess what i'm trying to get to
at a metaphysical level at an
existential level
is
that
the logical conclusion
seems to me
that
the
life
to its fullest
iteration as a human
involves
almost necessarily so
the spiritual
aspect
right that not that denying that aspect
is denying the most basic function of
your brain yeah
i think the point is well taken and you
know certainly um
you know an atheist for example might
say they don't feel that kind of thing
and um you know part of my answer to
that is that you know even though they
may not necessarily find religion
uh or something
identified yeah
yeah or or spiritual or something
spiritual uh as fundamental to who they
are um most people even those people who
are highly materialistic will turn to
music or nature or you know some
activity
gives them
they're seeking something they're
seeking some kind of understanding some
greater knowledge some greater
connection um they just don't call it
the same thing and so um you know i
think that's part of it uh you know
arguably speaking i mean
no matter what uh function of humanity
or of human beings you're talking about
uh there's there's a bell curve you know
there's always going to be some people
who are going to be more
drawn to something rather than less i
mean as you were talking about that
question i was thinking about sex i mean
obviously sex is fundamental to the
human condition i mean we gotta have sex
in order for the species to survive but
we don't have to have sex i mean you can
go through your whole life and not have
sex if you real you know i mean there's
a way to do that but uh but you know
it's it's not quote unquote sort of the
natural way of being the natural way of
being is to want to procreate and want
to have sex and and that's part of you
know we were built with the hormones and
the drives and all that to to make all
that happen so so i think in a similar
kind of way yes i mean you know we we
all have that that interest we all have
the the brain that wants to seek answers
to the big questions uh you know an
atheist has come to a different
conclusion about the nature of the world
they've come to the conclusion that
there isn't a god versus someone who's
come to the conclusion that there is one
um they're they're looking at the
universe they're looking at data they're
looking at information they're thinking
about things and that's all part of this
process it's sort of how the brain
engages the world around us to try to
understand it and try to understand our
relationship to that world and so i do
think it's still a fundamental part of
who we are but we all do find different
ways of of going at it and and that's i
think how to address that kind of
question
[Music]
so just a really technical question i'm
just calling on your years of expertise
okay my mom during the hippie days
dropped acid when i was in utero how did
that [ __ ] up my brain that explains
everything right
right
what happened well i wish i could tell
you in my giant brain from that horizon
probably if it was a one-time thing it
probably didn't have too much of an
effect you know the the problem always
is is that there's just so many things
that affect who we are and you were
probably far more affected by the ways
in which you were raised
than by you know having her drop acid
while you were in utero there but um but
you know what i mean it could have and
it also depends on when you know and how
early and how much development there
already is um but but you know even when
we're going back when we were talking
about drug-induced states you know
certainly when when people who are
younger are doing drugs like marijuana
and so forth it really does you know
change the way their brain is
functioning as it's developing and so we
do have to be careful about that but but
everything influences us and and you
know whether it's our parents our
teachers our our friends our own
personal experiences with different
things um the world around us you know
uh i mean that's the brain is constantly
in just this perpetual interaction and
uh you know we we put something out
there it comes back and then we keep
going with it and uh and it really it
it's quite remarkable you know how how
all of us uh develop individually and
and again that that's part of what i
really have come to appreciate is that
each one of us you know each of our
brains is kind of in the same boat we're
looking at the world we're we're looking
at an infinite world
using point you know zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent of
information about that world and yet
somehow our brain tells us we got it all
figured out right and well said you know
and which which again you know hopefully
people you know that's part of what we
try to teach people is let's not all be
quite so certain of what we think we're
so certain about because
our brain is really just doing the best
job it can and we come to conclusions
that kind of work for each one of us
but
but we are very limited in what we can
ultimately know about the world and and
maybe we got to work together a little
bit better to help each other figure it
out best episode ever
[Music]
okay lightning round let's do the
lightning round uh-oh shall we i didn't
know there was a lighting are you ready
for this yeah this is going to really
test your brain functionings
ready okay
when do you feel most connected with the
universe
i feel most connected with the universe
when i am doing my own
philosophical meditation uh searching
for the answer to these questions what
do you want your deathbed to look like
physically or yeah yeah physically
spiritually i well i don't know not
metaphorically yeah
uh i think i would want it to be simple
um you know
to me you know i'm part of the universe
and so i guess just a simple burial to
let all of my
cells and molecules just go back to
everything else and come back up in the
next thing
uh describe your soul in 10 words or
less oh
uh
i would describe my soul as someone who
continues to strive to ask questions and
find knowledge
in as unbiased a way as possible that's
good what's one thing you know for sure
that i don't know anything for sure
what is your biggest fear
my biggest fear
um
i guess my biggest fear is
um
is is is failure that i could have
stopped
if it's something that i could have done
something about to prevent the failure i
don't mind failing but if it's something
i could have prevented then that i don't
like that
assuming there is a heaven
what does heaven look like um i've
always sort of thought that if there's a
heaven it's it's just kind of being part
of the universe and and being able to go
all over the world all over the universe
to be able to see the incredible
grandeur of it and finally what is your
life's big question
the last big question i think is
actually my easiest one to answer which
is what is the nature of reality and how
do we get to know it
hmm i like that that could be the
question of our entire podcast what is
the nature of reality and how do we get
to know it we get to know how do we
witness it how do we get to know what is
real
yep how do we get to know what is real
delicious that's what drives everything
i do
dr andrew newberg thank you so much for
joining us this was super super
fascinating uh can i call you a neuro
theologian can i call you absolutely
yeah all right absolutely
neuro theologian andrew newberg thank
you very much for joining us thank you
so much
[Music]
all right uh
easily one of my top three favorite
episodes top three top three easily i'd
say top seven i don't know about three
yeah
but that's good you really you you miss
a lua that was you you bring her up all
the time i love a luau i loved her too
she was pretty awesome amazing but
insofar as uh podcasts about religiosity
in the brain yep top two yeah absolutely
no question no question uh yeah really
unbelievable i really resonated with a
lot of what he said and i
i certainly appreciated his humility
about not having any kind of certainty
about
uh any of this you know can you have a
spiritual experience and it's just some
neurons firing in the front of your
brain or your parietal lobe um or is it
uh really actually happening we didn't
actually and this is what i love about
doing this show with you we didn't get
any answers
we just shed some light on an on a
fascinating issue one that he's spent
his entire life researching
even
the most basic fact this idea that
spirituality is a neurological
phenomenon i mean that's a fact but even
then
he wasn't willing to say that it existed
only in the brain yeah he was like well
maybe actually the brain is just
latching on to a thing that exists out
there
and that's what it that's what the
brain's actually doing it's not it's not
in other words uh
creating the experience it's tapping
into a thing a real thing which is you
know it's it's refreshing to hear a
scientist that open about the
possibility of
a thing being out there he's open to all
possibilities and i love that idea too
of like what is real and i i do think
about that a lot what is real what is
reality because we're we're kind of
wired to believe and kind of culturally
uh programmed to believe like what is
real is the material stuff in front of
us
and dealing with that next thing the
next email we need to return or the text
we need to return or the next job um
difficulty that lies in front of us but
but what is really
real and how can you see with eyes kind
of bigger than our material eyes i know
i'm sounding a little bit vague and
hippie-ish right now but there's a
spiritual reality i believe that goes
hand-in-hand with the material reality i
can't really say like oh the spiritual
stuff's over here and and the material
stuff's over here they're they're linked
they're connected and how can i really
be attuned to uh both things at the same
time does that make any sense no it does
it does i think that was kind of what i
was going for when i was talking about
how
that you know whether it's deliberate or
by accident or evolutionarily or not
that we are just
um
made to be like this that we're made to
to think in these terms we're wired for
that we're wired for the profound yeah
for transcendence for divinity so
yeah it what do you think dear listeners
what do you think about all this you
know uh you can find us on social at
reza aslan at rayne wilson you hashtag
metaphysical tell us what your brain is
on these days is it religion
spirituality drugs where do you find god
how does it all connect and uh i would
especially like to hear from you uh you
know sort of self-identified atheists um
people who might be kind of offended by
the idea that our brains are designed
for spiritual experiences uh what do you
think about that i mean does that does
that
challenge what you think or do you just
feel like well yeah but it's still a
choice whether you want to explore those
experiences was this all a bunch of
poppycock yes thank you again to our
guest today neurotheologian
dr andrew newberg i'm gonna call myself
that from now on i think that that would
be a good title for you we'll see you
next time thanks so much for listening
bye-bye
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samasa de jazz harris lane mick demaria
hashem himself and dj lubell
metaphysical milkshake is produced by
amy s choi and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsay cradlewell
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin original music by jeff
tang and scott tang
[Music]
the latest study i'm working on is on
the relationship between sexuality and
spirituality so there we go that's right
now you got my attention
there you go
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you